well as the covet pandemic continues mgm
resorts taking their guest
accommodations to the very next level
within
cobit 19 testing thank you for joining
us at five i'm bryan loftis and i'm
denise valdez the company is also
planning some safety changes in order to
prepare for large conventions again
joe muller is live on the strip with the
company's new health and safety plan
joe yeah the goal with all this is to
make
customers feel more safe and provide
more options for them when they
do come here to las vegas or when they
visit one of the mgm resorts
properties now the new changes to their
health and safety program were announced
today
this has been something in the works for
months in room cover 19 testing
are available to any guests at mgm
resource this is being launched as more
international travelers are making their
way to las vegas and we move towards
welcoming back
large conventions mgm resorts leaders
say they have been getting more people
looking for testing options as some
areas require it when they return
visitors say it isn't a bad option to
have
it's a great idea i think you know
that's one of the things that we've seen
and appreciated about las vegas there's
a lot of customer service
and so i think that's just another way
to extend that
there are a few test options you have in
your room one provides results in 24 to
72 hours and the other has results in
about 20 minutes they will cost you
anywhere from 140 to 230 dollars and
results
are delivered electronically also part
of this plan
options for large events such as
screening options arrival arrangements
site cleaning protocols
and physical distancing now those
options are up to event organizers now
back out here live as more people
get the vaccine mgm resorts will look at
options for conventions or organizers
to add proof of vaccines to their
criteria for attendees that
of course is up to the event organizers
as well reporting live here near the
strip joel muller news